the Joe Rogan experience what is New
York like right now you know I've been
there I left I've been here a month now
you know I have a place down in Orange
County and New York was all [ __ ] up
and it's all boarded up yeah my
daughter's there I live downtown way
downtown and I was going out like an
hour a day you know that's it I just
went out an hour there we could take a
walk and there was the streets are empty
yes
3:20 at night now after the looting they
destroyed Soho yeah you know it's just
destroyed you know and the cops are very
timid and and it's all [ __ ] up I mean
it's all [ __ ] up I I don't I don't
know what happens there I mean I don't
know I don't know how it happened like
seen the cops just standing around or
they were looting the art galleries in
Soho while they were smashing Fifth
Avenue in fact I don't know [ __ ] is this
I I don't know it's like the end of the
world you know de Blasio's the worst
[ __ ] I'm not a political guy at all
Joe like not at all but he's the worst
[ __ ] human that maybe walks the face
of the earth I kid you not and you know
I owned an apartment in Manhattan for
like nine years and when he became the
mayor within a year you saw even six
months right you saw like these [ __ ]
changes I'm going I'm out I'm selling my
[ __ ] place and I sold my place what
changes all kinds of [ __ ] the cops
basically they have one hand tied behind
their back he changed all these laws
stop and frisk that Ana some needed to
be changed some not just the homeless is
everywhere all of a sudden the trains
are impossible there's all kinds of [ __ ]
going on you know and I have to blame
the mayor I mean there's you know where
I live downtown this listen I'm
compassionate to the homeless I don't
know the answer which is why I'm not the
[ __ ] mayor but they're everywhere
same thing here you know yeah our our
governor was the mayor of San Francisco
which is the craziest [ __ ] place
you've ever seen in your life when it
comes to almost be huh it's a column and
now after kovat it's like ramped up 40%
the homeless situation there is it
doesn't even make sense like you're
seeing these beautiful homes and there's
campsites in front of them and these
people have to come out of their houses
and you know tiptoe around needles and
broken bottles and and people [ __ ] this
might get worse hey dude you're covered
with AK economy you know collapsing
that's it yeah well that's what that's
what was happening with the Cova two in
New York because listen these guys
standing on the corner they're
panhandling
there's no one there was no one to get
money from I mean there was no one to
pay until the streets were completely
empty
Broadway downtown you could shoot a
cannon to it not a car yeah mark Normand
you know in the comic Markel arias guy
filmed a bunch of [ __ ] with him just
running around New York City with empty
streets nobody around how weird
Wall Street is empty all these places
that a packed or empty I don't know the
answer and with the cops I don't know I
mean I just don't know I mean it's all
so bizarre and I think so many people
are either gonna resign from the force
but definitely not join the force
there's a lot of guys that are thinking
about it's a tough job man for very
little pay and you put your life at
stake and just public opinion of the
force is down so low I don't get it
listen I know if God forbid I had
trouble I call a cop I'm no cop well I
play a cop now you know I've been on
Blue Bloods for five years I play it to
death I'm Pro cop you play cops you're
just playing the detective ated the
homicide detective
yeah we went from wiseguys to detectives
it's a fine line they're fine line but
yeah but I agree New York is my daughter
had just gone back and really depressing
man you know you haven't been right no
I've been in California since March
first I was in New York before that and
so yeah I got couldn't go back really
but I live here in there both places
yeah there was a little easier here up
in Santa Barbara area I love it up there
yeah a lot easier to be
quarantined Erica's yeah outside and
backyard and stuff like that yeah the
beach it's like Santa Barbara is the
perfect size but I I mean I was in New
York we they shut us down March 13th
well with two and a half episodes to go
we just got shut down and then they you
know then you couldn't even go out of
the house two days later I mean I wasn't
aware of anything I mean the trains were
packed I was taking the train and [ __ ]
and I went to a concert a few days
before Wow at the Beacon Dave Matthews
and Jackson Browne there's a [ __ ]
concert but nobody said anything you
know and Jackson Browne got sick yeah
yeah yeah maybe at that concert you know
maybe but then it was just I was there
for two months and it was gloom and I'm
in a building yeah so you got to watch
the elevated [ __ ] door man the thing
you know or the food in you know scrape
makes me crazy wipe off the package
don't wipe off the Patridge wear gloves
don't wear gloves it's a very very
confusing time nobody knows what the
[ __ ] is going on
[Applause]